[Musik]
hallöchen lieben heute gibt's ein ganz
besonderes rezept denn wir machen weiter
mit kapitel nummer 2 bis 20 bastian
cheesecake ihr wisst ja alle seit dem
letzten video haben wir da so ein
bisschen was losgetreten
denn nun bist hier ganz milde
ausgedrückt und für alle die sich mit
bekommen haben ich glaube das sind die
wenigsten unter euch sich jetzt noch mal
ganz kurz die geschichte von anfang an
es hat so begonnen haben sondern ich
haben uns verliebt verlobt und dann
verheiratet
anschließend sind wir nach anteile in
den urlaub geflogen das waren die
flitterwochen und zwar zu kalt in
antalya also sind zwar im inlandsflug
einmal rüber nach istanbul istanbul hat
uns so verzaubert das im september
wieder nach istanbul geflogen sind und
dann hat er geschrieben clique problem
sei passiert schließlich bist so lecker
und ich habe gesagt nein ich will kein
verbrannten cheesecake essen das
schmeckt doch nicht hab ihn probiert
habe mich verliebt und habe ihn dann in
deutschland einmal rekonstruiert und
nach meinem eigenen rezept nachgebacken
und dann haben wir den halb aller halbs
ausgelöst und die ganze welt von
deutschlandpakt diesen san sebastian
cheese cake pops gehen raus allerdings
markiert haben allerdings geteilt haben
ich habe auch immer fleißig report und
ich kann auch hier gerne noch mal ein
paar post einfügen und jetzt geht es
weiter mit chapter 2 das heißt das
kapitel geht weiter wir haben uns
überlegt wir machen den schoko san
sebastian seine idee richtig
also ich hab noch nicht gesehen ich habe
sie noch nicht gesehen ich habe auch
geguckt nein gibt es nicht und deswegen
habe ich gedacht okay ich stehe hier und
präsentiere euch das rezept hat mal
wieder so ein bisschen getüftelt und es
kann direkt losgehen zubereitung ist ja
auch wieder super easy superschnell und
das endergebnis kann ich euch jetzt
schon mal sagen 1 806 die küchenmaschine
und verwende jetzt hier in ruhe hat mit
der gummilippe falls ihr so was jetzt
nicht da habt dann nimmt ganz einfach
ein schneebesen und rührt kräftig weil
es geht wieder darum alles zu verrühren
und nicht auf zu schlagen das ist ganz
wichtig ausgenommen hinweis weil es im
letzten video so ein paar
unstimmigkeiten gab
ich benutze doppel raum frischkäse sie
ist das der salz schmeckt habe jetzt
hier diesen entdeckt von kaufland von
der eigenmarke bio und ich habe aber im
classic san sebastian schiek rezept
philadelphia benutzt hatte ich euch
jetzt ethisch mit der salsa und viele
haben sich dann auch vertan und haben
nicht angeschrieben oder kiki ich finde
kein frischkäse ohne seit aber ohne sand
und salz sondern doch zwei verschiedene
dinge
weil seit es immer enthalten aber es
geht darum dass es nicht zu salzig
schmeckt dann dem ich heute den von kabi
und gibt ihn jetzt zuallererst mal in
die rührschüssel in einer küchenmaschine
gibt da noch zucker und vanille extrakt
hinein und dann wird das ganz langsam
miteinander verrührt
[Musik]
im nächsten schritt gehen wir ganz
langsam die lauwarme seine mit dazu auch
wirklich nur auf niedriger stufe ganz
kurz miteinander verrühren und
anschließend kommt schokolade zum
einsatz hier nimmt die am allerbesten
60-prozentige die habe ich jetzt in der
mikrowelle geschmolzen bei geringerer
wattzahl und anschließend auskühlen
lassen so dass sie nicht mehr ganz so
heiß ist und es gebe ich das auch mit so
massen auch wieder nur ganz langsam
einrühren
[Musik]
als nächstes kommen die eier dazu die
farc will ich vorab gibst du dann ganz
einfach zum masse und dass sie ganz kurz
einrühren und das gute ist dass wir
diesmal eine weniger benötigen als im
klassischen rezepten san sebastian
cieslik weil die schokolade hier
ebenfalls bindet so andy jetzt kommen
bei kakao und speisestärke zum einsatz
für die bindung und für noch mehr
schokoladig kite einfach vor opfer
mischen und dann mit zum masse 7 damit
auch keine klümpchen entschied so das
ist jetzt wieder fertige teig der ist
mal wieder sehr flüssig kann sich gerne
mal hier nahaufnahme zeigen bericht auch
schon mega gut und dadurch dass der
ebenso flüssig ist verzichte ich auf
einen tortenring weil ein tortenring ist
zwar teuer kann man darin backen und
später auch noch dekorieren aber für
flüssige tage zum backen ist eher
weniger geeignet weil er definitiv immer
etwas unten ausläuft und deswegen nehme
ich wieder eine aus auf sichere liegt
die betonung auf auslauf sichere
springform die müsste dir aber alle seit
dem letzten video zu hause haben und
dann seid ihr da bestens ausgestattet
wichtig ist jetzt noch wie ihr die
auskleidet hier ist 20 zentimeter im
durchmesser auch sehr wichtig der kuchen
ist halt relativ mächtig kann man sagen
und deswegen ist die größe perfekt und
habe ich jetzt den boden schon
ausgekleidet mit seinem bug trend spray
und jetzt auch noch mal an den seiten
mit backpapier an
auch sehr sehr wichtig
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich den teig eingefüllt und
gleich kommt noch ein wichtiger schritt
da brauche ich gleich dich hamza super
super einsatz kommt aber gleich erst
vorab ganz kurzer hinweis wichtig dass
ihr den ofen freiheit der muss nämlich
heiß sein wenn der koch noch reinkommt
und zwar auf 220 grad ober und
unterhitze beim klassischen san
sebastian cheesecake hatte ich um luft
verwendet damit habe ich bei dem rezept
die besten ergebnisse erzielt hier bei
dem schoko teilt er gerne oben und
teilzunehmen
und er kommt dann gleich in den backofen
für 25 maximal 26 minuten aber auch
nicht so lange wie der klassische und
ganz wichtiger schritt kommt jetzt ham
wa einmal wieder 20 mal klopfen damit
die bläschen auch hausen das hast du gut
gemacht dass wir so viel glück gebracht
und es konstruiert wieder machen auf
jeden fall ihr zuhause auch 20 mal
ungefähr einmal klopfen gerne ein tuch
darunter lägen dann ist nicht so laut
ist und dann kommt er wie gesagt für 25
bis 26 minuten in den backofen
[Musik]
übrigens im unteren drittel backen und
danach bitte seid mir nicht böse aber
danach 68 schon auskühlen lassen der
muss ein bisschen länger aus können als
der klassische aber ein ergebnis lohnt
sich also ab in den ofen damit
[Musik]
für mich sieht er einfach perfekt aus
und als ich dem backpapier an tab
gemacht habe kam mir direkt so ein
schoko geruch in die nase
also wenn ihr so weit sein das
backpapier einmal abnimmt dann achtet
mal auf diesen geruch und jetzt kommt
der moment der momente erzählte
angeschnitten
ich bin so aufgeregt
[Musik]
da kommt man sieht hier schon dass der
mega cremig ist und ganz traditionell
einmal stürzen
ja das ist hier drin hier das habe ich
nicht vermischt was ist man jetzt ein
zweites stück ab aber die konsistenz ist
perfekt man gleitet so gut durch hat der
ist sowas von perfekt
[Musik]
und zur feier des tages habe ich mich
hier in unserem text die table gesetzt
und mache jetzt hier die live probier
stunde
ich sehe dass gleich eine kiki die
höchstwahrscheinlich ausrastet weil ich
mir nur vorstellen kann wie lecker
schmeckt klassiker erst mit dem löffel
unterziehen so cremig sehr schokoladig
aber ihr dürft euch jetzt nicht
vorstellen dass das so eine richtig
süßes schoko bombe ist dadurch dass wir
die nicht frischkäse genutzt haben
schmeckt er auch noch einen hauch frisch
diese kombination ist echt mega gut mega
deal würde ich keine schokosoße drauf
machen würde ich mich auch keine
vanillesoße auch nichts mit erdbeeren
also ich würde es genauso pressen
jeder der schokolade mag wird den schoko
san sebastian cieslik lieben damit ich
mir ganz sicher ich lebe ja auch
schokolade deswegen bin ich gerade
verliebt und habe voller rosarote brille
auf
also ich mache mir jetzt noch ein paar
gemütliche stunden mit diesem kuchen und
dann sehen wir uns wahrscheinlich beim
nächsten video vorher müsst ihr
unbedingt ein daumen nach oben da lassen
ein bisschen geschaut habe und ich bin
auch dafür dass im anschluss auch noch
handels live action zeigen nicht mal
schauen auf jeden fall so hinterlassen
wie gesagt auf jeden fall eindeutig nach
oben schreibt in die kommentare was zu
sagen haben wollt ihr noch eine dritte
variante soll die geschichte weitergehen
oder nicht entscheidet und ansonsten
bisher hat persson sebastian cheesecake
schreibt lassen wir ihn für austauschen
schreibt einen kommentar und dann sehen
wir uns auch beim nächsten rezeptur
lecker mir scheint so gut
durch das jetzt machen wir die texte
aber du musst halt
aber das tut jetzt richtig gut das ist
zwar so ein geiler schokokuchen wurde
sagt jetzt vom geschmack kann nicht
wieder da san sebastian also der normale
ab der schmeckt auch richtig geil so ein
bisschen großartig ja genau richtig so
eine prämie großartig
du bist einfach der voerder herrliches
posten des betroffenen keine ahnung was
du da machst du das schaffst keine
ahnung
du bist einfach krass wer 4000 kitas ist
dann einfach dort nach oben
[Musik]